un vestiaire de joueurs de rock et de
ligue de garage était un des derniers
sanctuaires macho qui résiste aux
époques
est ce que c'est vraiment ici on
retrouve landes québécois moyen
chose certaine c'est qu'il est pas
toujours facile par les temps qui
courent d'être un homme
or on en entend de plus en plus vouloir
réhabiliter l'image des vrais mâles à la
maison au travail et maintenant au petit
écran dans l'heure qui va suivre vous
allez en entendre certains des comédiens
connus au québec se révolter rien de
moins
le réclame maintenant de véritable rôle
de héros non plus de [ __ ] de la
veille
ou est ce qu a dit catherine wasquehal
et d'ex en paix
quand un peu tanné devant dgo les images
de go faible atelier à côté d'un espèce
de femmes toute puissante et sans aucun
défaut parfaite
moi je n'ai plus qu'une grosse interview
de bonnes choses pour que ça prenne
vraiment la réalité ça représente un
symptôme québécois en soi quelque chose
qui dans l'inconscient collectif
québécois je pense kg est quelque chose
dont il faudrait qu'on se débarrasse au
plus sacrant l'oiseau jeu soit pas
capable mais je me sauve en lego fort et
tv puis résister prévient le nombre de
go fait blouson intelligent
la semaine du 6 avril dernier a été très
dur pour l'image de l'homme québec
c'était la fin de saison de plusieurs
téléromans lundi soir nous un personnage
principal de l'ombre de l'épervier
incapable d'accepter son sort se lance
dans une mer déchaînée
il disparaît ce programme d'histoire
même s'était créé par un homme ça reste
fondamentalement pour éliminer une
vision féminine de la vie d'un
personnage central pour moi d'épervier
ça reste quand même pauline c'est de
l'eau compenser le bloc central
ceux ci sont le fait des efforts
incommensurables pour rendez nous
jugeons très fier du travail qu'on a
fait quand même c mais il reste que la
réalité de communes cc c'est quand même
pauline le bloc pour moi qui le dit mais
c'est nos savants sociologue qui disent
que l'homme québécois en général est
quelqu'un de torturé qui se sent un peu
menacé bon ki-moon cartonné emploi a
peur de le perdre mètres dans l'axé
tout ça ça fait à quelqu'un qui est plus
porté à rester poignée de banques à
s'ouvrir
mardi soir de la même semaine une autre
fin tragique
cette fois c'est promis mais personnage
principal de bouscotte qui s'enlève la
vie
reconnaît qu'elle québec a l'un des taux
de suicide des plus élevées du monde
surtout de la part des jeunes faut dire
entre 20 et 30 qui examine ben c'est pas
pour rien bon je pense que la télévision
là encore représente un point de vue
là-dessus et c'est ce que ce soit le
personnage de barrameda vous scotche
celui des avis dans les faits les
galères non c'est des personnages qui
vivent peut-être malgré beaucoup plus
acérées ce que peut-être ben du monde
vivent dans leur vie quotidienne mais en
petites affaires détachées centre trouve
ça rend compte un homme de notre cible
est bourré de contradictions du fait
qu'il paraît ah non vu comme un pauvre
type un peu sale gosse devenir
responsable un homme regarde ça
objectivement mercredi soir c'est au
tour de marc aurèle du volcan tranquille
de connaître une fin tragique
tous trouvent eux aussi tongs ou par
mauvais temps
c'est quelqu'un qui mérite tout mêlé
mondragon
c'est la seule oui qui lui restait un
livre d'une prostituée il meurt dans les
bras de ses bras
j'ai perdu l'estiment de mes deux fils
ma fille aînée m'en veux florence pense
que je n'ai jamais aimé ma femme est en
colère contre moi et ma soeur me déteste
c'est ça que vous vouliez que j'apprenne
trompé sa femme
même si la mm je ne peux prévu qu'il
aime pas mais il la trompait j'ai occupé
de ses enfants jamais abandonné sa fille
quand elle avait 15 ans elle a eu un
enfant s'est arrangé pour clarifier la
fin a pu régler tout ça à vitesse sans
tenir compte des problèmes que ça
causait et tout à coup il meurt après
avoir fait un testament sous le coup de
la colère et il se retrouve dans un
espèce de purgatoire il se rend compte
qu'elle perd il a été dit le quand on le
voit dans sa famille on le voit non pas
en tant que ce moment où il y aurait pu
être super là c'est toujours un moment
où il y'aura t son coup il n'y a pas été
vraiment un repas où il est en colère où
il n'y a pas écoutés on revient toujours
à ce personnage l'oeuvre du père
m'entends j'ai donné mon 9
les images culpabilisante sont jamais
bonnes à la langue sont jamais bons il
faut qu'on finisse par en sortir
j'admets j'admettrai la démarche qui se
fait à la mesure où un jour on sortira
de cette image depuis pas militante
l'offre sans qu'on s'en aperçoive espèce
s'est installée espèce d'image donne ou
plutôt faible en d'un téléroman puis on
savait pas soit plus et ce qui est
dangereux c'est ce qui est ainsi du bon
sens mais pas soit pas un bon jour les
patients atteints de jeu les faux choix
je vois des cinq jeux à l'unité lumière
monsieur le préfet tient pas debout oui
parce qu'avec les gros chars les robes
baby tous les aéroplanes
l'avenir de la paix ni sur le celi
touristes nous restons simples comme il
se doit par année passant à prendre là
on part est un homme extrêmement
malheureux qui est mort heureusement
jeunes puisque n'a pas été malheureux
trop longtemps mais qui est un homme est
très malheureux parce que ils n'avaient
pas de place ma mère prenait toute la
place lui en avait pas mais il a aimé
n'acceptez pas c'était pas tout à fait
conscient mais il l'accepté pas et donc
c'était un homme malheureux comme je
pense beaucoup d'hommes québécois
latéralement c'est devenu comme une
denrée quotidienne ou hebdomadaire
important pour les gens les gens qui
sont souvent les gens que tu sois dans
les soirées enregistre quand ils sont
pas là c'est devenu une denrée une chose
dont ils ont besoin dans laquelle donc
ils puisent des choses qui les touche
qui leur ressemble
dans toute notre dramaturgie québécoise
l'homme québécois est souvent quelques 2
torturer quelqu'un qui qui braque ou de
quelqu'un qui perd qui qui est de la
misère à prendre les choses en main et
de faire quelque chose avec qui tu sois
un peu mou depuis 40 ans la position des
hommes toujours était inconfortable car
la dramaturgie télévisuel québécois
il ya eu quelques moments où les hommes
ont eu un quelconque succès mais c'était
la préparation très artificielle très
superficielle sais pas d'où ça vient
figure d'autorité tel point qu attirante
là attendez que votre père harry bon
c'est ça la recherche est bonne mais le
bonhomme est déjà couché il ya déjà été
mis hors circuit
il est déjà complètement en dehors de
l'histoire du drame des complications
mais regardez la réaction du père et de
la mère mais dès le premier épisode
comme ça il ya déjà un jugement sur le
père plouffe sur cette figure d'autorité
la vieillesse non il veut pas assisté au
drame
il est à côté il est impuissant
c'est pas un père faible c'est un père
qui ne s'occupait pas de diriger la
maison il ya différence
vous comprenez père sans pouvoir la
maison voilà sans pouvoir à la maison
point faible il délégué son pouvoir et
sa force à sa femme
peut-être qu'ils étaient obligés et
c'est comme ça que ça se passe encore
dans le
dans les foyers moyenne suspens comme ça
que ça se passe chez vous non jamais
dans toute l'histoire des play off
tough enough mais ne soit capable
d'assumer une véritable figure de père
rassurant de père protecteur de perdre
responsables de ces enfants
véritablement il va toujours être à la
traîne de sa propre famille m'a donné la
passion quand ça passe ça fonctionnait
pas et que sa femme ça marche après
guillon à moi je paye son père il y
avait une réplique cris ou à le dire à
ma main c'est encore le petit bonhomme à
le dire à ma mère
encore oui et être sûr que ça a pris
beaucoup cela ne s'est pas anodin que la
plupart des hommes québécois de
certaines en rappel la femme maman
trouve sa débilité total mais il reste
que 80 % des hommes québécois de saint
quentin qui s'appelle la femme moment
alors au fond il était très dans un sens
propre à leur aventure avec le
matriarcat pillon les killers qui les
soutenaient qu'ils lisent supporter paie
pas on leur enlève dans l'espace de
quelques années sur trop de voir prendre
une place qui sont probablement pas prêt
à temps
n'achetez pas ne doit pas c'est un
espèce de s'adapter
il était un peu dans son monde
mais doit s'adapter à la fable moderne
qui a mené au mali par exemple ou à
l'épaule le joola qui comme à savoir le
petit téléphone mobile mais il me fait
pas plaisir à bascharage
moussavi avait des indices livrés
intericonicité côté de ça pour moi c'est
pas là c'est pas la gagne à taverne
c'est la gagne qui se mettent ensemble
pour aller éteindre un feu pour aller
sauver quelqu'un pour aller si c'est ça
qui est beau pippo est issu paul agon
qui vont faire la guerre qui vont les
tuer du monde suivante ils vont tout
faire pour qu'elle ait pas de morts
c'est c'est beau vous ne manquerez
d'identité est parfois oui d'amendé
c'est sûr mais de moins en moins en
moins mais il a fallu que je fasse de
l'ordre de me donner dans mes pensées
m'a mené tout au long de la vingtaine
que je fasse de l'ordre dans mes
rapports avec les femmes avec la femme
en général évidemment t il a fallu que
je
une espèce de réconciliation avec ma
propre voix devant tanguy l'image de
l'armée
peut-être cela tu es vraiment super plat
que je propose là peut-être ça c'est pas
vous avez conçu un projet télérama oui
je vois de la montagne je remonte à
l'image de la maintenant un personnage
fait c'est plutôt comme une espèce de
comité d'accueil des extrêmes plus mais
les personnages principaux sont des
enfants c'est un enfant roi mais ont
quand même dépasser enfants le cpo on
n'a pas une belle image de l'homme
d'un côté on a le père absent par son à
cause de son travail ne leur côté on ne
parlera de ça parce qu'il était
compétent mais c'est peut-être post deux
hommes dans la société ces deux hommes
qui font partie message positif de la
non pensée légaux partout et avec
l'impression inconsciente d'avoir le
petit bout de morale du bac c'est à dire
d'être un petit peu moins faim un petit
peu moins bon un petit peu moins forts
que les fans ici même si inconscients
puis c'est ce que si on continue à
nourrir sa nana dramaturgique dans la
télévision
on n'est pas sorti du bus etc